Rockwall police tell us they spotted the  Dodge Charger that had been reported  stolen from Midlothian in Ellis County  they tried to stop the vehicle the  driver refused and the pursuit was on  we're told drugs and guns were  eventually recovered from that car and  the baby in a car seat or carrier was in  the vehicle too next two men with the  baby switched to a white Dodge SUV that  was evidently in the possession of one  of those men they were followed by  police and Dallas County sheriff's  deputies on the ground and by a DPS and  a Dallas police helicopter in the air  and they wound up here at the lakewest  Head Start and day care center in West  Allis here we saw them go into the  building with the baby in that carrier  somehow they were able to walk through  open doors that were normally closed but  they were quickly arrested by the  officers and there were no injuries as  best we know